well the u.s government has released an
eagerly awaited report on
unidentified flying objects the federal
government is
unable to explain as many as 143 objects
encountered by military aircraft
in the last several decades despite
speculation in social media the report
does not suggest
aliens might be behind the sightings but
it does say that
identifying the objects or phenomena may
be
beyond the existing means of the
american military
dw reporter aaron tilton has been
following this story for us
erin it's good to see you here on the
set you know
ufos are unidentified aerial phenomena
as the government refers to them seem
like fantastic or spectacular
notions from a sci-fi movie so why is
the government taking them so seriously
well because at the end of the day it's
their job i mean if there's something
zipping around the airspace of a country
it's in the military's best interest to
figure out what it is because it's a
question of security both for their
military planes and also
for civilian aircraft as well and you
know it's not just the us government
that's actually looking into these
reports we do know that both the chinese
government
and the russian governments have similar
programs and they're looking into
similar reports above their airspace as
well
and you know reports like this have a
long history the united states first
started looking into reports of usf
of ufos rather actively as far back as
1952 if i'm not mistaken with project
blue books so at the end of the day
it's a question of security for them at
least from the military's perspective
why has this report generated such
interest online well it is kind of like
a perfect storm to generate clicks i
mean
if you think about it when we hear ufos
um we're kind of conditioned to think
that there's an extraterrestrial sitting
inside and we have decades of science
fiction
that tells us that ufos equals aliens
and unfortunately that's just
not the case but what also makes this i
think a little bit more interesting is
that
this isn't just some like uh yokel uh
country bumpkin reporting that they were
abducted or something like that
we're talking about highly trained
military pilots flying some of the most
sophisticated sensor packages that have
ever existed who are saying look
we're seeing stuff up here that we have
no explanation for we don't know what it
is
um and just the fact that the observers
are so credible makes it
really interesting and that's what's
gotten i think some of the speculation
flying to the degree that we've seen it
in recent weeks
so i'm going to ask you to speculate
probably based more on science now but
what could be behind these 143 sightings
well
if you're hoping i'm going to say aliens
unfortunately i'm going to disappoint
you because this is always the case
if you think it's aliens it's never
going to be aliens that's unfortunately
that's just not how our universe works
there is a lot of speculation about what
this could be ranging from
mistakes in the sensors mistakes in the
radar systems that they have
camera errors um also basically just
saying
that the some of the pilots might be a
little bit confused about what they're
saying
um at the same time the report itself
said that there are most likely physical
objects behind this that these aren't
just
sensor mistakes now if these are
physical things actually flying out
there that has people point to the fact
that this could be some type of new
drone technology
that we haven't seen before hypersonic
drones that can fly many times faster
than the speed of sound
now those are things that we know other
governments are looking into we do
we do know that russia china and the us
are developing those type of drones
so if this is some type of new drone
technology we haven't seen that would
definitely explain
why the military is looking into it and
taking it so seriously and at the end of
the day i would love to say this
makes us one step closer to saying we're
going to shake hands with e.t at some
point
but i think at the end of the day the
explanation is going to be a bit more
terrestrial unfortunately dw's aaron
tilton thanks for keeping us
up to date thank you